B, FaceTime video.
Oh, no.
Hey, B!
Oh no.
Well, what's, what's wrong.
Look at that hair.
You've gone for the top knot, B.
Well, it goes all over my
face otherwise, doesn't it, B?
Well, B, as you can see,
I've been having to make several
videos without you in them.
And I'm sick of it,
to be honest, I've got no one
to talk to in these things.
Aw, well, I'm sick of not being in them.
I've just got no one to talk to, period.
For those who don't know, Dan and I
for eight of the ten years
we've been doing this channel,
we've lived about 5,000 miles apart,
two different continents.
And currently due to
planetary pandemic situations,
we can't travel to each other.
Technically I can go to England
but I have a real hard
time getting back here,
and then we don't have cameras in England
and you can only come
here if you're a diplomat,
right?
I think it's if you're
a diplomat, the queen
or you're like American
or something like that.
So I've had an idea,
we can't make videos during the pandemic
but there's nothing stopping us
from making a video before the pandemic.
I mean, I can think of a
couple of problems with that
Right? Go ahead.
Firstly, that would require time travel.
Yeah. Yeah.
So that would be the main problem.
You're 100 percent right.
I was thinking if any
YouTuber had a time machine
it would probably be Colin Furze,
and we've never made a
video with him before.
He's always doing mad stuff.
So I think we'll get,
if we get hold of Colin
and then we'll just plan a
time when we were both free.
Yeah.
It's very rare that we were both together
but not filming Slow-mo Guys.
So when would be a good time?
I know you came back to England
for a bit because you were
like, just wanted a rest.
Yeah. There was a time
between Super Slow Show
and Planet Slow-mo
where I just had a
restful week in England.
We didn't film anything,
but we were both together.
Yeah.
Just having a laugh.
If Colin was free that week.
Perfect.
I think that might work.
We could sort out a Phantom
rental, nearby place.
Should I give him a,
should I give him a bell?
Yeah. Give him a call.
Alright, hold on.
Hey, all right Colin? How's it going?
Hey, you all right
Slow-Mos? What we up to?
Wondering what the chances are of you
having a time machine.
What's the time machine sitch?
Yeah. What's the time machine sitch?
I've kind of got a time machine.
I've kind of got, I've got
well, maybe 50, 50% of it.
50% better than nowt,
to be honest.
Well, yeah. I mean
that's at least 50% more
of a time machine we've got.
Full blown Delorean.
Yeah, that's pretty sweet.
Colin. We were wondering
about a cheeky collab.
Are you free, or should I say
were you free in November of 2017
November, 2017.
Let me think.
All right.
There will be a gap,
when I was building the TIE
fighter up at Tom's farm.
You come and see me then
and I think that would work.
Brilliant, Colin, pick
us up when you're ready.
Stick the kettle on, yeah?
Excellent. Right?
I'll get it sorted and I'll
presume we had a lovely time,
well, I'll know in a minute, won't I?
Yeah, yeah, I look forward to it, wait...
Looked forward to it? No.
I don't know
Yeah, can't wait, couldn't wait.
I couldn't have waited. What?
Hello. I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow-mo Guys
and today we're not in my back garden.
In fact, you may realize
where we are already.
We are in a prop shed though.
That's true.
Quite different from ours.
Ours has, you know
bits of string, balloons,
condoms, maybe a spade.
This one's got Wolverine
claws, magnet boots
real mantles like lathes
and all sorts of cool stuff.
It also contains Colin Furze.
Yes, me. How's it going?
Thanks for having us Colin.
It's a very famous room and I'm,
I'm delighted to be stood in it.
So what we're going to
film today, in slow-mo?
Well. I've got one of these.
Just casually lying around.
The pulse jet engine.
Now these things are super cool.
They make, like, loads of noise.
They go red hot.
They spit fire out.
They're awesome.
But everyone always asks
me how do they work?
What's going on inside?
So I thought, well, you know,
you two could come in really handy here
It seems like we should
point one of these at it.
Phantom Flex 4K right through the window.
Yep.
You get a thousand frames a second easy.
Sounds good.
Are we doing it here in the shed?
No, we are not doing it in here.
Okay, good, good
Onward!
I'm bringing my cuppa.
Jealous.
Now we're in the field.
Right? Look at this dry stone wall here.
Lovely little view, ah,
the pulse jet engine.
Here we are.
Here we are then, pulse jet,
Slow-mo Guys got the
high speed camera set up
they don't know what's
going to happen yet,
he's just going to push the trigger when
he thinks he should do,
right, let's get it started.
I felt like my heart,
I bet if I was wearing a heart monitor
that would register.
I would say the term for it is it thrums.
Thrums!
Yeah. I think that's the right word.
It is kind of like the Eye of Mordor.
Yeah, the Eye of Sauron
Not sure I wanna look down there now.
For those of you who don't know
what the pulse jet actually is,
if you haven't seen Colin's videos
what it's doing is creating explosions
in this chamber and it sends a wave
of pressure out the long
and short ends of the tube.
That's the jet part.
As the wave expands
it leaves a near vacuum
behind in the chamber.
So fresh air and oxygen rush
in the short end and hot
gases are sucked back
from the long end
which ignites a new burst of fuel.
And the whole cycle repeats
itself, many times a second
which is why it's very
useful to be filming this
with the Phantom.
Shall we then now we've got that,
Should we try and rev it a bit harder?
Well, I'll rev it up a little bit.
Push the red button and
then switch it off, yeah?
Colin is now operating the Phantom
so we're not even needed, honestly.
Fire always looks kind of CG to me
when it's this slow
this is 3000 frames a second.
It looks like it's just
going in one direction.
But if I speed it up slightly
you can see that it's sort of
swaying inside the cylinder.
Yeah. Should we start filming
down the spout then?
Yeah, lets start filming down the spout.
We haven't even got it glowing yet.
Cause we can get the whole
thing glowing red, nearly.
So you may have noticed here
that the camera is about,
what, a foot from danger?
Actually it's probably-
14 inches.
Every man overestimates.
Always quite scary shoving a
Phantom down the danger hole
but that's where you get the best footage.
This is like the best angle.
All right, good.
It's going back down a little bit,
isn't it?
Back down the barrel.
It used to suck more air in.
If we do rev it even
harder, you will get flames,
that might travel further.
So move back on the
camera and rev it harder?
Yeah, I think so, I think
your 14 inches might-
So we're a little bit further back
and Colin is going to give
it all the beans this time.
Now I don't know if you saw it, but when
that was first getting going,
there was a massive flame.
Like all around here.
You see that?
I didn't see it.
It was like right on your head.
My head or his head?
Both of your heads, it was massive.
What? Can't have been.
It was, it was just like, I
guess some excess loose gas.
That was just-
Well that's always good to know.
A bit of loose gas flying around.
If it's just burning itself.
It's not using us as burning material.
It's actually just like a nice heat.
Is that smoke, or is that flame?
Have a look at this, what is this?
What am I looking at?
That's blue flame.
Let me see.
Yeah. You see, you can see it breathing.
Oh, that's wicked actually.
So for this one, my job
is just stand still.
Dan is a human background.
I'm a background.
You're doing the job of the two C stands
I'm also wearing ear defenders
because I'm going to go deaf
if it starts going right next to my head.
So this is the first shot
we're doing from the outside.
Just looking at, see if we're
getting flame coming out.
The spouts.
See if you can film the
spitty spitty stuff.
Am I safe here?
Yeah, you're fine.
He says.
We'll just, if flames come out, just move.
You'll be all right.
I love it
For a brief moment, you'll be hotter.
It was kicking a bit that one, wasn't it?
Good, good reflexes, went right
over the top of your head.
My hoodie is like burning to a crisp here.
Feel my hoodie, this
was soft a minute ago.
Feel this, it's gone like crunchy.
That's all right, stick
it in the washing machine.
It'll be fine.
Brilliant.
You feel the heat, Dan?
Yeah. Rippling.
I can see it.
Imagine if models used
that as like, you know
when the wind blown hair with
the winds being blown around.
Well, if the hair was wet,
it wouldn't be for much longer.
It's a good point.
It's coming out the side of the glass.
What is?
The flames the gas and
the flames are coming
out of the side of the glass.
Oh, whoops.
Colin, you've got a leak!
Oh, yeah, it is.
See some of that?
It follows the outside,
there's like a beefier part,
here in the middle
and then the flames
come around the outside
and then clap together
and go back down again.
It's amazing how much it can go on.
Yeah.
In a fraction of a second.
And it's, yeah, cause it is
doing that in milliseconds.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Blowing out, sucking-
You wouldn't think it could
and that's just all on its own.
Right? So we've slow-mo'd it,
we have a better idea of
what's going on inside.
I think we just get it going red hot now.
Yeah. Just leave it
going for, a lot longer?
Yeah, just keep it
going, just let it glow,
Maybe then the glass may break.
Cause I am shocked that it has not broken.
Will the steel melt
I mean, what?
I don't think it'll melt
I've never got a stainless one to melt
What is the melting
point of stainless steel?
I think it's 1200 degrees.
Oh, that is hot.
Oh, the heat!
You can't get anywhere near it.
It's singeing the table.
I don't know.
My hands are quite cold, actually,
I reckon I could get pretty close.
That was redders in there.
It's actually changed the
color of the glass as well.
Oh yeah.
It's gone all green.
Oh man.
This is lush as a radiator though.
Probably wouldn't want to touch that.
Oh lovely.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice in an English winter, right?
Yeah.
That was some lovely looking footage.
Big thanks to Colin Furze
for letting us come
and film his pulse jet.
It was class.
Colin is secretly my
favorite British YouTuber.
So make sure you give
him a big wet subscribe.
Subscribe to us as well, if you want.
And we will see you in the next
episode of the Slow-mo Guys.
How long would it take you to get home,
if you took this, like as
your method of propulsion?
Are you talking home to Texas?
Yeah, yeah.
Long old time. Just sitting on the ocean.
Good luck with that.
I was pretty close, almost got singed.
How am I, how are my hairs looking?
Well, the eyelashes, hang on.
Really? Really?
Can you see like the turned up edges?
Yeah. You got a little bit of ginger
at the end of them now.
Oh no! No!
I'm proud of these bad boys as well.
You're proud of them?
You called your eyelashes bad boys.
Yeah. There's so long and lovely.